dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here in many
previous episodes we talked about
generative adversarial networks a recent
new line in machine learning research
with some absolutely fantastic results
in a variety of areas they can
synthesize new images of animals create
3d models from photos or dream up new
products based on our edits of an image
a generative adversarial Network means
that we have two neural networks
battling each other in an arms race the
generator network tries to create more
and more realistic images and these are
passed to the discriminator network
which tries to learn the difference
between real photographs and fake forged
images during this process the two
neural networks learn and improve
together until they become experts at
their own craft and as you can see the
results are fantastic
however training these networks against
each other is anything but roses and
sunshine we don't know if the process
converges or if we reach Nash
equilibrium Nash equilibrium is a state
where both actors believe they have
found an optimal strategy while taking
into account the other actors possible
decisions and neither of them have any
interest in changing their strategy this
is a classical scenario in game theory
where two convicted criminals are
pondering whether they should snitch on
each other without knowing how the other
decided to act if you wish to hear more
about the Nash equilibrium I've put a
link to kin Academy's video in the
description make sure to check it out
you'll love it I find it highly exciting
that there are parallels in AI and game
theory however the even cooler thing is
that here we try to build a system where
we don't have to deal with such a
situation this is called generative
latent optimization giallo in short and
it is about introducing tricks to do
this by only using a generator network
if you have ever read up on font design
you know that it is a highly complex
field however if we'd like to create a
new font type what we are typically
interested in is only a few features
like how curvy they are or whether we
are dealing with a serif kind of font
and simple descriptions like that the
same principle
be applied to human faces animals and
most topics you can imagine this means
that there are many complex concepts
that contain a ton of information most
of which can be captured by a simple
description with only a few features
this is done by projecting this high
dimensional data onto a low dimensional
latent space this latent space helps
eliminating adversarial optimisation
which makes the system
much easier to Train and the main
selling point is that it still retains
the attractive properties of generative
adversarial networks this means that it
can synthesize new samples from the
learned dataset if it had learned the
concept of birds it will be able to
synthesize new bird species
it can perform continuous interpolation
between data points this means that for
instance we can produce intermediate
states between two chose and furniture
types or light fixtures it is also able
to perform simple arithmetic operations
between any number of data points for
instance if a is males with sunglasses B
are males without sunglasses and C are
females then a minus B plus C is going
to generate females in sunglasses it can
also do super-resolution and much much
more make sure to have a look at the
paper in the video description now
before we go we shall address the
elephant in the room
these images are tiny our seasoned
fellow scholars know that for generative
adversarial networks there are plenty of
works on how to synthesize high
resolution images with more details this
means that this is a piece of work that
opens up exciting new horizons but it is
not to be measured against the 10th
follow-up work on top of a more
established line of research two minute
papers will be here for you to keep you
updated on the progress which is as we
know staggeringly quick in machine
learning research don't forget to
subscribe and click the ballet icon to
never miss an episode thanks for
watching and for your generous support
now see you next time
[Music]